Nowadays, it isn't unusual for a big-screen
blockbuster to run well over two hours, but
even with lengthier run-times, filmmakers
aren't completely free to include every scene
they may envision for the final product.
Scenes end up on the cutting room floor of
every blockbuster — and others are scrapped
before they're even filmed.
While the theatrical film is often all the
better for the cuts, it's always interesting
to hear about what might have been.
In the case of Black Panther, most fans certainly
had no complaints regarding the theatrical
cut, which had a 134-minute runtime.
Still, we might have gotten even more.
Here are the Black Panther scenes you didn't
see.
T'Challa and Nakia go for a run
Director and co-writer Ryan Coogler said the
movie constantly changed throughout filming,
ultimately resulting in the loss of some potentially
important moments.
One such moment would have given viewers a
better glimpse at Wakanda through the eyes
of T'Challa and Nakia as the pair went for
a run.
Coogler told Digital Spy:
"I was so in love with Wakanda, I wanted to
explore it more."
In addition to revealing more of the secretive
nation, the scene would have also introduced
some important new characters — namely,
the parents of Nakia, whom the pair would
have met at her childhood home at the end
of their journey.
Coogler explained:
"Think of it as a Rocky-style jog or a Muhammad
Ali When We Were Kings-style jog."
However, the scene had to be cut early on
due to budgetary constraints.
Coogler said he was ultimately okay with the
fact that they never got to shoot the scene,
considering it likely would have been cut
for time anyway.
Still, it's sad to hear that viewers won't
have a chance to get this extra glimpse of
Wakanda in any DVD extras.
There's always room for some run action in
the sequel, though.
Okoye and Ayo flirt
Black Panther has been hailed for its representation
of minority characters, but one cut scene
has caused controversy among some communities.
The scene reportedly featured Danai Gurira's
Okoyeflirting with Florence Kasumba's Ayo,
another member of the Dora Milaje.
Vanity Fair first called attention to the
scene in April of 2017, when writer Joanna
Robinson said she'd seen a cut of a scene
in which the Dora Milaje were dancing together.
In the scene, Okoye reportedly looks flirtatiously
at Ayo, telling her, "You look good."
When Ayo tells her the same thing, Okoye smiles
and says, "I know."
Many were hopeful that the scene was an indication
that the movie would feature the LGBT storyline
from the comic World of Wakanda, but Marvel
later crushed those hopes by saying the comic
wasn't used as source material for the film.
Instead, Gurira's Okoye is depicted in a relationship
with Daniel Kaluuya's W'Kabi.
Black Panther co-writer Joe Robert Cole was
vague in an interview when asked about the
potential storyline, saying he didn't remember
the scene in question.
But he did add that:
"[There were] a few conversations around different
things, different directions with different
characters, and characters that we may have."
Kasumba herself later spoke out on the matter,
seeming to say that the scene had existed,
revealing to Vulture:
"There were a few scenes that have been cut.
[...] Whatever their reason is, I can't tell you,
because nobody told me about whether it's
in or not."
Perhaps that scene will make it into the home
video extras to make up for the missed opportunity.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!